- 36?
- No.
- Come on.
(whimsical music)
- Hi.
- My name is Andy.
- Andy, I'm Danielle.
- How are you?
- I'm good, how are you?
- Zach.
- Heather.
- There we go, we met.
Yeah, I'm Will.
- Hi, Will, I'm Shar.
- Today, we are blindfolded
and we're gonna try to
guess each other's age.
(dinging)
- Alright.
- Hm.
What movies did you watch growing up?
- Of course, a lot of Disney
but I was watching the
old-school animation.
None of this Finding Nemo CGI craziness.
- Do you use Snapchat?
- (laughing) I do not use Snapchat.
- [Danielle] You do not use Snapchat?
- No.
- Okay.
- What was your favorite childhood snack?
- I'm trying to think. I
liked fruit snacks a lot.
Who was your favorite band
when you were in high school?
- Bjork was my favorite musician.
- I'm gonna take a stab at it.
I'm gonna guess that you are 31.
- No.
- (groaning) Okay.
- Backstreet Boys or NSYNC?
- Backstreet Boys.
- Got it.
- Are you Backstreet Boys?
- I didn't like any of them.
- Okay.
- I loved NSYNC when I was younger.
And then I still loved JT.
- For me, I was a Destiny's Child girl.
- [Will] Okay.
- Did you vote for Bill Clinton?
- Yes.
- [Zach] 36?
- No.
- Come on.
- So were you in elementary,
middle, or high school
when Monica Lewinsky and Clinton?
- Monica Lewinsky was like,
what, that was like '98?
I think I was pre-kindergarten.
- Oh wow, he's a baby.
- I think she's 23.
- I'm 22.
- Do you remember the
first CD that you bought?
- I do. (laughing)
Don't judge me, it was MC Hammer.
- I don't know if this is
gonna work as well, but
do you still have cable?
- Yes.
- Okay, alright, cool.
Then I'm gonna put you
in and around the bracket
with my siblings who are
just a touch older than me.
- Well I should,
let me preface this by saying
it's not my cable, it's my mama's cable.
- Oh, okay, well that's--
- But I stream it.
- Alright, well, then
we're back to. (laughing)
- The first dance craze
I remember really hitting
was The Macarena.
- Okay.
- Do you know
what the Macarena is?
- (laughing) Yes, I do.
We did that in PE.
- When you were 18?
- No, 'cause I had The Macarena.
- We had The Macarena at different times.
- 28?
- No. (laughing)
- [Zach] 38?
- No.
- Come on.
- What was your first cell phone?
What kind?
- A Nokia.
The one that had the game
you play Snake on it.
- 27?
- No.
- 31?
- Oh my God. (laughing)
Am I closer?
- You're closer.
- Are you 33?
- I am!
We did it!
- I'm trying to high-five you.
- We are literally 10 years apart.
- What was the first
car you remember having
when you were a kid?
- I remember a station wagon.
- That had the wood paneling on it?
- Yes.
- You'd either have to
be born in the early 80s
or the very late 70s.
39?
- No, but really close.
- 40?
- Yes.
- I mean, I can't see you directly
but I wouldn't have
guessed that you were 40.
- Oh, God. I'm gonna embarrass
myself on the Buzzfeed.
- You're right there, you're right there.
- 24.
- Yes, boom.
You are 28 years old?
- No.
I'm 29.
- Oh okay, well, I was close, I was close.
- You were very close.
- Yeah.
- 29?
- Nope.
- 30?
- No.
- Am I close?
- 32?
- No.
- Did you ever have a Blackberry?
- No, I never had a Blackberry.
- I give up.
- Yay.
- How old are you?
- 38.
- That was really tough.
(laughing)
That was really hard.
The Snapchat question was good.
- Yeah, 'cause no one I know
in their 30's has a Snapchat.
- To get the exact number was difficult
but to get in the range,
once I knew what her cartoons
were when she was a kid
it was pretty smooth sailing from there.
- I didn't know what I was stepping into.
You know, you get presented
with the blindfold.
You don't know what you'll end up doing.